Traduttore: Elena P
Revisore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
Era il 19 luglio del 2000.
Era un momento particolarmente felice
della mia vita
perché mi ero appena laureato
in giurisprudenza
e ho deciso, come molti fanno,
di festeggiare questo traguardo.
La mia passione è il viaggio
e quindi vado negli Stati Uniti.
Arrivo in America, a Fort Lauderdale,
dove decido di ripassare anche l'inglese,
perché da lì a poco,
una volta tornato in Italia,
avrei cominciato a lavorare
in uno studio di diritto internazionale.
È una serata di agosto, il 29,
sono le 10 di sera
e devo andare a bere una birra con Andrea,
un ragazzo di Napoli
che ho conosciuto nella stessa scuola.
Percorro Las Olas, la via principale
di Fort Lauderdale,
una via con bar, ristoranti, locali.
Svolto a sinistra,
passo un piccolo ponticello d'ingresso
e sono in Isle of Venice,
una via privata circondata dal mare.
Una via dove tutto era sicuro:
la sorveglianza, il fatto che l'entrata
e l'uscita fossero uniche,
il fatto che non ci fossero vie di fuga.
Parcheggio in fondo e vado
a chiamare Andrea.
Suono, aspetto, sono in ritardo
per cui lui si è già mosso
da questa strada
e ritorno all'auto.
Giro l'angolo e vedo quattro persone
con un passamontagna.
Mi fermo.
Non faccio nulla.
Uno mi guarda, mi urla qualcosa
e mi spara.
Cado a terra.
Cado a terra e arrivano le ambulanze.
"Who did it? Who did it?"
"Chi è stato? Chi è stato?"
I paramedici continuano a chiedermi
questa cosa per tenermi sveglio.
Mi portano in ospedale, sono ancora
vigile.
Guardo negli occhi il chirurgo e gli dico:
"Non voglio morire, mi aiuti!"
Le pallottole, scoprirò dopo,
hanno colpito
il fegato, il polmone
e il midollo spinale.
Stavo veramente morendo.
Passano 35 giorni di coma indotto,
mi risvegliano, ma mi danno
una notizia sconvolgente:
non potrò più camminare.
Mi aspetta un periodo difficilissimo.
Vengo riportato in Italia.
Quattro mesi di riabilitazione a Vicenza
in Unità Spinale
per imparare a spingere
la sedia a rotelle.
Cosa si può fare?
Credo sia un nuovo inizio per cui
l'alternativa è solo una:
pensare che sia la fine.
Infatti,
la mia prima domanda è stata:
"Ma perché mi hanno sparato?"
E la polizia mi dice:
"Eri nel posto sbagliato al momento
sbagliato.
Non erano dei professionisti.
Noi non li abbiamo mai presi.
Però, vedi, un ladro professionista
va dove ha tante possibilità di fuga,
non dove le possibilità di farcela
sono pochissime.
Questi ragazzi,
quello che possiamo immaginare,
è che siano degli sbandati".
Eh, bella consolazione, però io mi trovavo
con la mia vita stravolta,
con un pensiero alla mattina
che era identico alla sera:
'voglio ammazzarmi'.
In questa situazione, mio padre mi dice:
"Ma perché non fai questo, non fai quello,
non fai quell'altro?"
Però io alla fine rifiutavo tutto
finché mi dice:
"Perché non torni in barca a vela?
È la tua passione".
Sì certo, ho sempre avuto la possibilità,
la fortuna, di vivere il mare
con una barca a vela.
Però, ho pensato:
'Devo tornarci muovendomi sulle ruote,
come prima mi muovevo sulle gambe.
Esisterà al mondo una barca
che mi permetta di far questo?'
Non c'era. C'erano delle esperienze
di vela e disabilità
con delle barche piccole, ma non c'era
quella barca che mi avrebbe consentito
di tornare a una vita precedente,
che sembrava assolutamente
non poter più tornare.
E così, avevamo una possibilità.
Arrendermi alla realtà o plasmarla
per raggiungere il mio obiettivo.
Abbiamo trovato un cantiere italiano,
Mattia & Cecco,
e abbiamo cominciato a costruire
un catamarano,
un catamarano perché non si inclina
lateralmente,
quindi con la carrozzina tu potevi
muoverti.
Costruendolo, però, ci rendiamo conto
di come questa barca in realtà
può insegnare tante cose.
La barca diventa più bella della barca
che il cantiere costruiva normalmente.
Ha lo stesso numero di cabine e di bagni.
Dove passo io passano meglio tutti.
Ma allora, perché in una città
io non posso muovermi?
Perché quando vado a un ristorante
la mia domanda non è:
"Il pesce sarà fresco? Mangerò bene?"
Ma la mia domanda è sempre la stessa:
"Posso entrare da solo? E se mi serve,
posso usare un bagno"?
La risposta spesso è: "Ci dispiace,
non siano attrezzati."
Ecco, da questo stimolo continuo,
da questo -
da queste difficoltà,
da queste difficoltà io dico:
dobbiamo fare qualcosa!
Ma perché se si può costruire una barca,
non si può costruire una città
dove tutti si possono muovere meglio?
Dove passo io, una mamma con un passeggino
ha meno difficoltà,
e così una persona anziana e direi anche
un bambino.
E quindi, nel 2003,
nasce lo 'Spirito di Stella'
che è il nome del catamarano, ma è anche
il nome di un'associazione ONLUS.
E dal 2003 al 2017 facciamo
moltissimi progetti.
Il primo "Back to USA".
Voglio tornare a Miami.
Voglio tornare dove la mia vita
è cambiata.
Lo voglio fare insieme ad altri ragazzi
disabili e insieme a grandi velisti
come Giovanni Soldini e Mauro Pelaschier.
Ma lo voglio fare anche per dire che oggi,
purtroppo,
è più facile attraversare l'oceano
che muoversi a Milano in sedia a rotelle.
Io vorrei che questa cosa cambiasse.
Per cui da quel momento, abbiamo fatto
tante battaglie,
abbiamo portato 5.000 persone disabili
in barca a vela gratuitamente,
abbiamo portato il messaggio dal mare
alle università
per insegnare ai progettisti a progettare
in una maniera
più universale, più utile per tutti,
un concorso di idee dal titolo
emblematico:
"Pensare e progettare per tutti".
(Applauso)
Nel 2017, abbiamo pensato di fare
un grande viaggio,
un viaggio da Miami fino a Venezia,
un viaggio con 20 equipaggi diversi
perché 20 erano le soste, le tappe,
che noi abbiamo fatto.
Persone abili, persone disabili, militari,
civili, imprenditori,
di qualsiasi professione o provenienza
geografica.
Perché vedete, nella barca
è come nella vita,
solo che tutto è molto più compresso
e quindi se si litiga in barca, lì si è.
Ecco allora, persone così diverse
sono riuscite non solo a convivere,
ma a fare una grande impresa.
Perché?
Perché avevamo un obiettivo.
E questo obiettivo era raccogliere
dal Segretario Generale dell'ONU
la Convenzione ONU dei diritti
delle persone con disabilità.
Ce l'ha consegnata proprio
António Guterres.
E questa Convenzione ha attraversato
l'oceano
finché l'abbiamo portata a Roma,
a Papa Francesco.
(Applausi)
Al Dalai Lama
E a tante -
(Applausi)
E a tante altre persone.
E ancora questa convenzione
viaggia con noi
e ogni volta che possiamo la raccontiamo,
ad esempio in un'occasione come questa.
La Convenzione è uno strumento importante,
è uno strumento che però va conosciuto.
Vi voglio mostrare un breve video
che racconta questo viaggio.
(Musica)
(Fine musica)
(Applausi)
Per me il viaggio, poi, ha avuto
un significato particolare
perché in mezzo all'oceano ho sposato
Maria
e WOW è diventato Weddings On Waves.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Ma non è solo il mio viaggio.
Io, in fondo, ho fatto pace con il destino
tanti anni fa, sono felice,
faccio delle cose che mi piacciono
e che penso siano utili,
ma è il viaggio di tutte le persone
che hanno a cuore i diritti di ognuno.
Noi volevamo far capire
che ci vuole rispetto a questo mondo
e rispettare l'altro vuol dire alla fine
rispettare anche se stessi,
vuol dire creare le condizioni
perché la società sia più equa.
Ma vedete, le difficoltà, poi, hanno anche
un vantaggio a volte,
perché ci portano a ragionare
in maniera diversa,
perché ci fanno scoprire nuove strade.
Se c'è un ostacolo, noi dobbiamo pensare
al modo in cui lo possiamo superare.
Dobbiamo trovare dei nuovi modi.
L'invenzione nasce da questo.
Il telecomando della televisione,
penso che sia un oggetto che tutti noi
conosciamo molto bene,
è nato perché il suo inventore era stufo
di vedere l'amico in sedia a rotelle
che doveva dal divano trasferirsi
con fatica sulla sedia,
raggiungere la mensola dove stava
appoggiata la televisione,
cambiare canale
e continuare così.
Gli SMS, nati in ambito militare,
una volta che la telefonia mobile
è diventata comune
servivano alle persone sorde.
Il sistema di pagamento POS è nato
da un concorso di idee
per il pagamento elettronico
dei non vedenti.
I tasti sono tattili e una persona
non vedente può digitare sia il prezzo
che il codice crittografico.
È lui che chiude la transazione.
Nell'uso, è uno strumento
che noi usiamo tutti i giorni
e probabilmente se chiedete a una persona
non vedente neppure sa che è nato per lei.
Ecco allora che si possono oggi creare
degli oggetti
che sono veramente universali.
Voi mi chiederete: "Ma, è tutto a posto?
Le ingiustizie sono finite?
I diritti sono rispettati?"
No, però abbiamo uno strumento.
È proprio la Convenzione ONU
dei diritti delle persone con disabilità,
che abbiamo custodito
in questo lungo viaggio
e che ancora oggi, come vi dicevo prima,
ci accompagna.
Dobbiamo però conoscerla.
Io vi chiedo:
diffondete questo messaggio.
(Applausi)
Voi non potete farmi tornare a camminare,
sicuramente,
però voi con il vostro atteggiamento,
non parcheggiando in un posto
per disabili,
creando rampe dove c'erano scalini,
creando nuovi telecomandi, creando ausili
come questo, che mi permettono
di muovermi in una città,
di muovermi in una città vecchia
come sono tante città italiane,
ecco, voi potete, non solo permettermi
di avere una vita piena e felice,
ma io credo, che facendo prevalere
l'uguaglianza,
il rispetto gli uni degli altri,
erodendo quelle che sono inutili
e devastanti diversità,
contribuirete a creare una società
migliore.
Grazie.
(Applausi)